salut romain ya encore une manif
et oui pourquoi à l'écran une vidéo et
qu'il n'a pas fait
ok dans ma vidéo sur les règles je vais
faire un petit disque les moeurs qui
n'est pas passée inaperçue toutes les
femmes n'ont pas leurs règles et toutes
les personnes qui ont leurs règles ne
sont pas des femmes
alors pour plein de raisons et notamment
dans le cas des personnes transgenres
qui méritent évidemment une vidéo dédiée
voilà le moment d'en reparler est venu
c'est aujourd'hui alors déjà avant de
commencer on va se mettre d'accord
l'expression changer de sexe ça reflète
pas la réalité
du coup vous allez me dire pourquoi tu
appelles tu as vidéo comme ça alors là
bas c'est parce que c'est l'expression
la plus employée notamment par les gens
qui savent pas précisément de quoi il
s'agit et que le but de dtcc justement
de donner des infos au plus grand nombre
donc on va commencer tout de suite on va
parler de trans identité parce qu'on
veut c'est pas changé de sexe c'est
beaucoup plus complexe et l'idée c'est
d'expliquer ça juste avant de comprendre
comment ça se passe en pratique c'est
pas mal de comprendre de quoi on parle
parce qu'il ya plein de mots est plein
d'expressions pas forcément clair et
même pas forcément exact qui sont
utilisés sur le sujet alors je vais pas
vous faire une explication au texte mais
je vous mets un lien vers un lexique
dans la description de la ville juste
pour comprendre
on est tous avec un sexe biologique nos
organes génitaux externes et internes
pour résumer et miss destituée prostate
vu le vagin clitoris d'utérus etc
on va pas en parler aujourd'hui mais
sachez qu'on peut aussi avoir des
caractéristiques biologiques des deux
sexes et donc à la naissance
vous savez comment ça se passe une vue
hop et une fille un pénis hop c'est un
garçon que ça c'est le sexe et le genre
c'est tout ce qu'on accroche dessus au
sens figuré tu parles de codes sociaux
piercing le genre c'est ce qui définit
ce qui est féminin et ce qui est
masculin et tout ce qui va avec toutes
les conventions sociales qui y sont liés
les traits de caractère les goûts
et c'est en grandissant il arrive qu'on
se rende compte que notre sexe et notre
genre bah ça colle pas je parle de
personnes qui se sentent qui se vivent
comme appartenant à un genre qui
correspond pas au sexe biologique qui
leur a été attribué
et pour ces personnes on peut se poser à
un moment de leur vie la question de
faire coïncider les deux et donc de
faire une transition c'est à dire de
vivre et d'être au regard de la société
selon leurs propres jambes et pas celui
défini par leur sexe la transition ça
peut aussi concerner des personnes qui
ne se sentent pas appartenir
exclusivement à l'un de ses deux jambes
mais bon concrètement comment on fait
c'est pas juste une opération
chirurgicale
c'est un peu plus compliqué une
transition même si la loi permet de la
faire et qu'elle a évolué encore
aujourd'hui ça reste un parcours du
combattant
notamment parce que le genre ça se
retrouve dans plein d'aspects de la vie
l'aspect physique c'est vrai mais aussi
l'aspect psychologique sociale et l'état
civil par exemple
d'ailleurs pour une transition tout le
monde n'a pas forcément le même parcours
tout ne choisit pas forcément
d'intervenir sur tous ses aspects
évidemment ce qui complique les choses
c'est qu'il ya toujours des gens qui
viennent coller leur nez dans les
affaires des autres et donner leur avis
voir leur jugement mais bon on va
s'intéresser au concret et à la façon
dont ça se passe en france
on va commencer par l'aspect physique
bon alors déjà à ce stade tout le monde
choisit pas la même voie on n'est pas
obligé de passer par un parcours médical
pour certains et suivant les cas ça
passe par de la muscu des vêtements
compressifs pour masquer les formes ou
des séances d'épilation les greffes de
cheveux etc
on peut aussi apprendre à modifier sa
voix chez un orthophoniste voir faire un
peu de chirurgie esthétique au niveau du
visage
chacun fait en fonction de son apparence
de départ et de ses envies ou de ses
besoins pour celles et ceux qui
choisissent la voie médicale ça commence
chez le psychiatre la loi n'existe pas
mais je trouve qu'une majorité des
médecins et des chirurgiens qui
interviennent dans les transitions
réclame un certificat d'un psy ce que
dénoncent les associations de personnes
trans donc vous l'avez compris le psy
c'est pas pour être accompagné dans son
coming out ou soutenu dans son parcours
du combattant c'est juste une espèce de
feu vert pour la suite officiellement
pour déceler s'il n'y a pas une
pathologie psychiatrique qui
altéreraient le jugement est
officieusement pour se couvrir au cas où
la personne changer d'avis
coûts et décidé de faire un procès cette
évaluation elle peut être longue voire
très long une fois qu'on a le sésame en
poche on peut théoriquement choisir les
médecins et les chirurgiens qu'on veut
pour faire sa transition
il ya les équipes hospitalières du
spécialisées auxquelles certaines
associations de personnes trans ont pas
mal de choses à reprocher mais il ya
aussi des praticiens qui font ça dans le
privé vous en douter quand on entreprend
une transition
les choses peuvent être compliqué à
mettre en place et du coup c'est
toujours une bonne idée d'être
accompagné et prendre les conseils d'une
association ensuite
là encore il n'y a pas de procédure
standard il ya un certain nombre de
traitements possibles mais rien
d'obligatoire
la première possibilité c'est
l'hormonothérapie c'est à dire prendre
des hormones masculines usante ou
féminisant tu selon le genre vers lequel
on transition ça permet de développer ce
qu'on appelle des caractères sexuels
secondaires
en gros la voir les poils l'aspect de la
peau
la distribution des great sur le corps
le développement de la poitrine et
c'était il ya plein de médicaments
différents qui sont données en fonction
des antécédents de la personne et qui
nécessite bien sûr un suivi médical pour
ce qui concerne les opérations
chirurgicales là encore il ya beaucoup
d'options c'est la personne qui choisit
ça peut être une rhinoplastie se faire
refaire le nez ou d'autres interventions
au niveau du visage ou de la pomme
d'adam ça peut être au niveau de la
poitrine une mammectomie c'est à dire
retirer les seins et reconstruire un
torse ou au contraire poser des
prothèses mammaires
et puis il ya la réassignation sexuelle
ce que les gens appellent souvent changé
de sexe et qui concerne les organes
génitaux
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
c'est loin d'être la majorité des cas
mais oui évidemment ça existe pour ce
qui concerne exclusivement les organes
génitaux
une fois de plus chaque cas est
particulier chacune et chacun choisit
l'intervention ou les interventions qui
lui correspond l'hystérectomie par
exemple c'est à dire retirer l'utérus
les tromper les ovaires c'est possible
mais ce n'est pas systématique
on peut aussi choisir de subir juste
d'une orchidée tommy c'est à dire
retirer les testicules ça permet par
exemple de diminuer les traitements
hormonaux et certaines personnes choisi
de subir la i do you pay s complète part
ça c'est le père médical ont dit aussi
souvent vaginoplastie c'est une
intervention qui consiste à façonner un
vagin mais aussi un clitoris des grandes
et des petites lèvres de façon
chirurgicale
les grands principes de cette opération
c'est que le résultat est une apparence
le plus naturel possible mais aussi bien
sûr qu'il soit fonctionnel sur le plan
urinaires et sur le plan c
pour arriver à ce résultat et sans
rentrer dans les détails on conserve au
maximum la peau et les structures de la
verge mais aussi les nerfs côté tennis
il ya plusieurs possibilités
la fal au ps d'abord polèse création
salus a fallu créer un pénis
littéralement là encore l'idée c'est de
se rapprocher le plus possible du modèle
original mais c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce que dans le cas
précédent on retire des trucs là il faut
en rajouter
la technique la plus courante c'est
prélever de la peau avec les vaisseaux
et les nerfs le plus souvent au niveau
de l'avant-bras mais aussi d'une cuisse
ou d'ailleurs ensuite on en fait un
pénis on le greffe et dans un deuxième
temps si tout va bien on peut y mettre
une prothèse qui permettra l'érection
c'est une intervention délicate qui ne
fonctionne pas parfaitement à tous les
coups il ya une alternative à cette
technique c'est la médaille de you
plastique on appelle aussi la méta en
fait quand on prend des hormones comme
la testostérone le clitoris grossit et
étant donné que comme on l'a vu dans la
vidéo sur le sujet ces structures sont
très semblables à celles du pénis sa
forme comme une sorte de petit pénis
l'opération consiste à le dégager pour
qu'il soit bien à l'extérieur cette
technique à moins de complications que
la fal au psl et les cicatrices sur les
avant bras ou sur les cuisses mais le
pénis est plus petit et il est parfois
moins fonctionnel encore une fois garder
en tête que tout ça ça concerne pas tout
le monde loin de là parce que de
nombreuses personnes n'ont pas recours à
la chirurgie il ya une espèce de
fascination par rapport à ça du coup il
ya une tendance à réduire les personnes
trans à leur corps alors que c'est plus
une affaire d'identité et de rapports
sociaux en marge des traitements
médicaux et chirurgicaux il ya aussi les
démarches pour changer de genre au
niveau de l'état civil changer de prénom
déjà ça se fait en mairie et le
changement de la mention sexe sur les
papiers ça c'est un juge du tribunal de
grande instance qui s'en occupe depuis
2016 la loi précise qu'il n'est plus
nécessaire d'avoir suivi de traitement
médical ou chirurgical pour changer de
sexe
au niveau administratif maintenant que
vous avez compris et avant de se quitter
on va faire le point sur quatre trucs à
ne pas dire à une personne trans
mais tu as encore tu as enfin que vous
demandent souvent parler de votre pénis
et de votre vagin comme ça vous nom
pareil en fait même si vous avez très
envie de savoir mais ça me regarde pas
mais comment tu fais l'amour même
réponse vraiment mais du coup c'est quoi
ton orientation sexuelle ça rien avoir
en fait ces paliers une personne trans
elle peut être les terreaux homo bi à
sexuelle etc
on sait pas si on doit dire il ou elle
alors petite astuce écouter la façon
dont la personne se présente et si vous
avez un doute à vous poser la question
gentiment si vraiment vous avez peur
d'être blessant vous temporisé vous
utilisez des pronoms neutre et vous
attendez d'être fixé voilà vous en
doutez il ya plein d'autres trucs à pas
dire mr on va déjà partir sur ces quatre
là ça sera un bon début
donc vous avez vu la transition c'est un
long parcours psychiatriques médicales
chirurgicales social administratif et
judiciaire c'est surtout un long
parcours
humainement parlant se heurte souvent à
l'incompréhension au jugement voire aux
agressions c'est ce qui fait que le taux
de suicide chez les personnes trans il
est beaucoup plus élevé que dans la
population générale savoir c'est
comprendre et c'est déjà un premier pas
et maintenant vous vous savez voit la
dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui je tiens à
remercier liam et l'association outrans
pour leur aide précieuse je vous mets
les liens dans la description on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos en attendant prenez soin de vous
et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]